the French Prime Minister attacks
President Trump abroad Democrats prepare
to take power and Republicans struggle
for a message I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show all righty well we
have a lot to get to today first of all
happy Veterans Day to everybody thank
you to all of our veterans all over
America and abroad we have a lot of
folks in the military who listen to the
show we always appreciate everything
that they do obviously we couldn't do
what we do on a daily basis everything
done that we do here on the show is only
backed by the enormous force and might
of the American military and the amazing
commitment that the men and women of the
American military have every single day
to keep us safe and to enshrine
constitutional principles not only in
the United States but for our allies
abroad and so I want to get to all of
that first let's talk about what you do
with your stamp so today
I believe the post office is closed but
let's say that you still need to get all
of your postage ready well what you need
to do then is go to stamps comm because
they have all the great services of the
post office without having to wait in
line the stamps calm you can get all of
those amazing services right from your
desk 24/7 when it is convenient for you
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package using your own
computer and printer the mail carrier
just picks it up you click print mail
and you're done we'll use stamps calm at
the Daily wire our offices in here at
the ben shapiro show to send important
letters and packages and merchandise for
the show as well we use it at my house -
I mean fact is that you can do it all
from your desk right now use promo code
Shapiro for a special offer it includes
up to fifty five bucks of free postage a
digital scale and a four week trial
don't wait go to stamps calm before you
do anything else click on that radio
microphone at the top of the home page
type in promo code Shapiro that stamps
comm promo code Shapiro again stamps
comm promo code Shapiro for that special
deal 55 bucks of free postage digital
scale and a four week trial
we're really excited to be broadcasting
today from WLS which is the home of the
Ben Shapiro show and will be in the new
year as well and it's it's great to be
in Chicago both my parents are from
Chicago as I was saying to the audience
beforehand I am originally I'm a White
Sox fan I've been a Chicago sports fan
my entire life which made me an
expatriate in Los Angeles but everybody
in LA is an expatriate
in any case it's great to be here but I
want to start today by talking about
President Trump overseas so President
Trump went over to France to commemorate
the 100th anniversary of the World
one armistice and it came complete with
usual amount of controversy President
Trump goes over there and it's very
rainy in France and apparently he was
supposed to go to a particular military
cemetery on Saturday he did not go
thanks to the rain people were saying
well this is obviously because he's
afraid that the rain is gonna mess up
his hair that is not true the reason
that he did not go is because they
couldn't get marine one in the rain over
to the site the next day he went over to
a different Military Cemetery he made a
speech there and when he did he actually
went out there without an umbrella I
think specifically to prove the idea
that he was not super afraid that his
hair was going to fall off as the rain
hit it but the real controversy emerged
when French President Emmanuel macron
led tributes to the soldiers killed in
World War one using in ceremony in Paris
attended by scores of world leaders to
pretty much go after President Trump and
the narrative about European politics
goes something like this
Europe is the great bulwark now against
world war because they are for
internationalism and the European system
and the people who are the real threats
are folks like President Trump and
Vladimir Putin and some of the sort of
nationalist leaders in Europe now
lumping all those folks together is
ridiculous president Trump and Vladimir
Putin are not on the same page on
virtually anything President Trump well
he likes to talk a good nationalist game
the truth is that his version of
nationalism is still tied to American
constitutional principle because it has
to be American nationalism is not the
same as French nationalism or Russian
nationalism or German nationalism in any
case this did not stop Emmanuel macron
from suggesting that he knew better than
anybody else how to prevent the
unimaginable hell of war in the future
and he said that nationalism is the real
problem and this does get to a root
issue with regard to how President Trump
talks and what the future of the Western
world is so McCrone spoke bluntly
according to the reuters of the threat
from nationalism he called it a betrayal
of moral values
he said patriotism is the exact opposite
of nationalism nationalism is betrayal
of patriotism here is what he had to say
ill exactically
die nationalism the nationalism on earth
isin
on his own news activatable a camp of
the desert on gun Sukeena summative
release you Sookie Rafi Viva Sakura
birthday to the Condor Sookie please a
pop town
for those who don't speak French like me
what he says his patriotism is the exact
opposite of nationalism nationalism is
betrayal of patriotism when we say our
interests come first those of others
don't matter we erase the very thing
that a nation holds most precious that
which gives it life and makes it great
its moral values now this is a very
bizarre statement it's very bizarre
statement for a number of reasons first
of all patriotism and nationalism are
not in direct conflict and to suggest
that patriotism is the exact opposite of
nationalism is to misunderstand both
patriotism and nationalism because the
exact opposite of nationalism would be
just by nature anti nationalism ready
for racing of borders it would be
internationalism and globalism
that'd be the exact opposite of
nationalism patriotism is not the exact
opposite of nationalism patriotism says
there is something specifically great
about our country now there is overlap
between patriotism and nationalism but
they're not identical so nationalism can
be used in a variety of ways you've seen
blood and soil nationalism in Germany
during World War two you've seen blood
and soil nationalism in Italy in
Mussolini's era you see blood and soil
nationalism in North Korea right now you
see blood and soil nationalism to a
certain extent in Vladimir Putin's
Russia patriotism is the idea that there
are certain fundamental principles to a
society that are so important that it
makes the society better
it makes us exceptional this is why I
think that Americans like to call
ourselves Patriots rather than
nationalists but to suggest that our
patriotism is universal that the
principles that we hold true that those
are universally applicable to anyone
inside and outside America's borders is
to ignore the fact that various
principles can take various forms all
over the world the founding fathers were
very much aware of this if you read the
Federalist Papers the founding fathers
specifically talk about how America was
built in a specific way because of our
unique history and because of our unique
geography and because of our unique
breakdown in terms of religion all of
that meant that these fundamental human
rights principles broke down in a
different way here than they might in
other places so for example just to take
an anodyne example the United States is
version of nationalism treasures the
idea of a bicameral a bicameral
legislature we have two houses of the
well there plenty of places that don't
right Israel is a democracy it has at
one house of the legislature the Knesset
does that mean that Israel is worse than
the United States what means that it's
different than the United States and how
runs now I would say that America runs
better because vibe our camp because of
our bicameral legislature but that is an
element where nationalism does not
necessarily mean opposition to other
nations and McCrone is doing something
that I think is actually ethically
dubious he's setting up a straw man when
he says that Trump says our interests
come first those of others don't matter
Trump has never said that we're what
Trump has said is our interests come
first specifically because the interests
of others matter if America is weak we
can't actually do good things for other
nations if America is weak if we can't
maintain our own values if we can't
maintain our own borders in our own
culture how exactly are we supposed to
offer opportunity for people who want to
come to the country if America were not
America if we if we put everybody else's
interests first we could not survive as
a country and placing nationalism in
direct opposition to patriotism means
that you are going to sacrifice the
interests of your own country for
supposedly the values of people of other
countries and you can actually see
Europe doing this which is why Europe is
dying in the United States is not
Europe's border policies have been
specifically designated toward the idea
that Europe owes other parts of the
world its fealty that Europe is supposed
to open its borders that all problems on
earth are the problems of the Europeans
and that means open immigration from
some places in the world where there are
a lot of folks who don't share European
values well that's that's very nice as
far as it goes but what it actually
leads to is a breakdown of exactly the
principles that Emmanuel macron wants so
Emmanuel macron many of the folks in
Europe on the Left they like to talk
about our principles our open borders
free flow of capital free flow of people
because we are not for nationalism we
are for patriotism and that means
letting in as many people as possible
well the result of that is a massive
blowback all across Europe what you're
seeing is precisely the opposite of what
McCrone and his friends actually want in
Europe what you're seeing is right-wing
governments elected in places like
Sweden in places like Norway you're
seeing all the Nordic countries move to
the right specifically because of
immigration issues because it turns out
that Emmanuel macron version of values
is not actually the same thing
as the Swedish version of values or the
Nordic version of values or the Italian
version of values what you are seeing is
a blowback from manual McCrone sort of
universalism toward the idea that folks
are saying listen we got to protect
ourselves first yes we have universal
principles but we can't help other
people can't give charity to other
people if we just leave our front door
unlocked if we allow people to raid our
safe there's no way for us to give
charity or to hire people or to be
strong on behalf of others in that the
first rule in a moral system is that you
have to be able to defend yourself
specifically so that you can help other
people and I think that by trying to
draw this distinction between patriotism
and nationalism McCrone is actually
demonstrating why Europe is falling
apart because again if your central
principle is that nationalism is bad
then when you end up with is
internationalism well internationalism
can be done in a number of ways but most
commonly it's done with multiculturalism
and when multiculturalism eats a
continent you see the continent fall
apart from within and that's what you're
seeing in Europe is birth rates plummet
as importation of foreign labor becomes
a way of life as much of that labor is
coming from places where people don't
actually share European values when
those values collapse there's nothing
left
what Veterans Day is really about and
what McCrone is missing is that it was
nationalism that led people to sign up
and go fight the Hun right it was
nationalism that led people to stand up
and say our nation is special our nation
is worthy of protection it wasn't that
we wanted to uphold the international
order it wasn't that we were there to
enforce UN obligations it was that
France wanted to protect itself Britain
wanted to protect France the United
States wanted to protect Britain and
France because it was in our interest to
do so
if it were not in our interest to do so
then we would not have fought that war
and the same thing is true of World War
two now it's certainly much more true of
World War two than World War one a war
that nobody really understands why it
happened it's far too complex but this
has real ramifications for how we pursue
foreign policy today so folks on the
Left will say that the United States
should really only pursue foreign policy
when it's not in our interest it's very
odd if you look at how the how the have
the left critiques the wars in which
America has fought typically they say
that America's wars that have been
justified are only justified when they
are not in America's interest right when
those when those wars are when we have
no connection to the outcome of those
so for example bad war is Vietnam why is
Vietnam a bad war specifically according
to the left it's because America fought
it for imperialism now in reality
Vietnam may have been the most anti
nationalist war of all time right we
really had very little interest in
Vietnam as far as what was happening
here at home
Vietnam was half a world away it was it
was an attempt to hem in the the Russian
and Chinese influence in the Far East in
a way that was going to have massive
impact at home at least for a long time
the left hates it though because they
say that it was just evidence of
American imperialism what's a good war a
good war is the war in Yugoslavia a good
war is the war in Libya a good war is
America putting troops on the ground in
Somalia places where the United States
has very little interest that's where
the left says it's a good war but when
the United States has an actual interest
then all of a sudden the war becomes bad
well this is a good way to destroy your
own base this is a good way to destroy
your own country because again the the
lessons of of every war are that
powerful countries need to act in their
own interest this is why President Trump
is president right now he's really
president because of a couple of
different forces that were evident from
from the Obama era force number one
President President Obama appeared to be
anti nationalist he appeared to be anti
patriotic he appeared to be a guy who
really cared very little about American
priorities and so America is a dark
force in the world
and Americans responded to that by
saying okay well this Trump guy's weird
and all but at least he likes the
country at least that guy is fond of the
country and thinks America has done good
things all over the world so I don't
know at McCrone thinks that he is his
doing here I don't know whether he
believes that the bulwark against the
breakdown of Western civilization is
going to be ripping into people who want
their country's interests pursued but if
so he's wrong he'd be better off making
the case that America's interest is in
the international interest in France's
interest is in the international
interest and Germany's interest is in
the international interest that in other
words we share interests those interests
are not identical we don't have to
eliminate borders we don't have to get
rid of what makes America strong or
France strong or Germany strong but we
share interests and as sovereign nations
sharing interest that's where we are
strongest which has historically been
the truth now the rest of the weekend
was kind of weird apparently there are a
bunch of topless women who charged
president Trump's motorcade in Paris
according to the Washington Examiner
they say at least three topless women
jumped to barricade to confront
President Trump
Sunday as he traveled to a ceremony I
don't know whose barricade they think
they're jumping or why that would be a
dissuasion for president Trump this
seems this is bizarre so feminist the
feminist group that has staged similar
topless protests they claimed
responsibility saying on Twitter that
the women were protesting the hypocrisy
of the event the words fake and peace
were written on woman's woman's body as
she ran within feet of the presidential
limo President Trump did his best to
open the car door but Secret Service
prevented him from doing so you do have
to you do have to admire the complete
lack of touch of being in touch with
reality that some folks on the Left have
when it comes to President Trump so much
so again that they think that it's going
to be like oh yeah
what is the logic there hey President
Trump is really gonna be upset if we run
up to him with our boobs head again
uh-huh okay said there's that again one
of the one of the reasons that I go back
to this nationalism patriotism point is
because it is very obvious that the left
believes that people all over the world
share interests people all over the
world have the same interest because the
only way you can make the case that
nationalism is bad and it's directly
opposed to patriotism is if you believe
that people all over the world have
basically at root the same interest and
this is a sort of point that was pushed
by politicians on both side of the aisle
from Woodrow Wilson all the way to
george w bush george w bush was fond of
saying that there was a yearning in
every human heart for freedom that is
just a lie it is not true there is a
yearning in every human heart for
freedom that is very often overcome by
other forces including a need to feel
part of a community including a need for
sanctity right Jonathan Hyde talks in
his book the righteous mind about all of
the different values that we hold dear
in our everyday lives in the United
States we believe that liberty is at the
top of the pyramid when it comes to
values but for a lot of folks it isn't
for a lot of folks its closeness to
their religious community for a lot of
folks it's a belief in in sanctity for a
lot of folks it's a belief in that
certain people must be separated from
and when you look around the world and
you're not a nationalist it makes me
wonder what you're thinking for example
this is a video of thousands of
supporters of Islamist parties who took
to the streets in Karachi in Pakistan
they're protesting a the acquittal of a
woman named Asia Bibi I'm going to show
you that video in just a second
first let's talk about you dressing a
little bit better so you see this jacket
that I'm wearing right now look at this
magnificent piece of clothing look at
this I mean feast your eyes upon it the
reason that you want to shop at Peter
Millar is because you want a jacket like
this and let's face it you're not gonna
have one unless you spend the money you
need to go to Peter Millar's Peter
Millar right now this is the Peter
Millar excursionists laser which makes
it sound like I'm actually going to
parachute into the middle of the
Amazonian wilds in this jacket I don't
know if that would work or not but I can
tell you that this thing is super
comfortable Peter Millar uses the
lightest padding and materials in the
shoulder for this particularly soft coat
because you don't actually want to feel
the weight of a blazer on your shoulders
after wearing it for a few hours also
it's pretty stylish from the width of
the lapels the button placement every
detail has been thought of so you can
look the part the style is modern the
fit is fantastic and you will feel
confident whether you're wearing it to
the big meeting or out for dinner and
drinks or whether you're doing
excursions across the Nile it's not
every day you buy a blazer and that is
why you ought to make a good investment
in the Blazer you do buy head over to
Peter Millar comm slash Ben check out
this blazer and some of my other Peter
Millar favorites be sure to use my link
and you will receive free shipping and a
leather travel caddy that's Peter Millar
I ll a our.com slash man that's Peter
Millar comm slash man go check it out
right now Peter Miller comm slash Ben
they make all their clothes are great I
have Peter Moeller slacks I have some
Peter Millar shirts all of them are just
fantastic and fantastically comfortable
go check them out right now
Peter Millar comm slash Ben that's Peter
Millar I ll a are.com slash Ben and
again you get that special deal when you
use the link you get free shipping and a
leather travel caddy as well okay so
look at this video from Pakistan and
what you will see is exactly what I'm
talking about in terms of people not
sharing values across the world this is
a video from Karachi Pakistan and
there's a woman in Asia Bibi Asia Bibi
is a Pakistani Christian woman she spent
eight years on death row for blasphemy
she was recently acquitted and thousands
and thousands and thousands of people
showed up in the streets of Karachi to
suggest that instead she should be given
the death penalty this is what it
actually looks like in Pakistan over the
weekend
[Music]
we stopped it there these are not folks
who share values right these are not
folks who you want invading your country
or coming into your country as refugees
if they don't share your values again
this idea that nationalism has to be
forcibly stopped so we can make room for
patriotism is the death of the West the
West can only stand on its own two feet
when the West knows its own values and
those values are specific outgrowth of a
set of core cultural and historical
circumstances unique to the West these
values are not held by everyone on earth
the values that we have in the United
States the freedoms we enjoy from
freedom of speech to freedom and
economics these things are the outgrowth
of 3,000 years of judeo-christian
development capped by an Enlightenment
that is rooted again in those same
values they did not spring up in the Far
East they did not spring up in South
America they did not spring up in Africa
they sprang up at one particular time in
one particular place because of a
certain set of historical circumstances
that were driven by a bunch of moral
values and when we abandon those moral
values in the name of everyone has the
same values we're all the same all
religions are the same in all cultures
are the same and we ought to treat
everybody as as exactly equivalent what
you are doing instead is you are
bringing in the threat in-house and
you've seen this particularly in Europe
and the United States you haven't seen
it quite as much because our immigration
policy hasn't been quite so welcoming
with regard to and thanks to proximity
we're not quite as close to places like
you're seeing here but you've obviously
seen the impact in crime rates in places
like France and Sweden you've seen
enclaves they've been formed of radical
Muslims from places like this who
believe in the same things that these
folks believe in there's a reason that
Asia Bibi is going to have to require
some sort of amnesty some sort of some
sort of sanctuary from the from this
country she's gonna have to take refuge
in your up she's gonna have to take
refuge in the United States because
again values are not always shared and
pretending that values are always shared
which seems to be a unique privilege of
Europe in the aftermath of two world
wars is astonishing also hearing the
Europeans lecture us on preventing World
War is really galling it's really
galling these are the folks who brought
us to world wars in
course of a century the two deadliest
wars in human history and then they're
going to teach us all about what they've
learned from those Wars at the same time
that their continent is falling apart
not just falling apart on cultural
grounds its falling apart on economic
grounds too and the fact is that the
euro is in serious trouble that the idea
of a confederation of European states
was good insofar as creating a bulwark
against Soviet oppression but it was not
good economically speaking because it
turns out they're a bunch of states in
Europe that aren't gonna pull their pull
their weight and this is what you've
seen from Greece from Spain you've seen
certain countries in the EU who are
supposed to be doing bailouts you've
seen in certain other countries in the
EU who are not gonna pay for those
bailouts and all of this is a serious
problem
all this is a serious problem so
failures to understand their own
economic interests have led the EU to
fall apart and what you're seeing is a
resurgence of nationalism now again I'm
not saying that pure nationalism is a
good thing it's not nationalism is just
a means it is not in and of itself an
end
nationalism isn't even an ideology it's
sort of like populism it's a tactic but
it can be a very good thing and
abandoning nationalism in favor of the
International global governance regime
is foolish and it's why President Trump
when he says globalist in the left hears
anti-semitism what he's really saying is
we don't want international bodies
governing for the United States how we
ought to do our business that's all he's
saying and frankly I don't see a whole
hell of a lot that is wrong with that
okay meanwhile there's a piece of news
that is that is really troubling and
nobody in America is is going to deal
with it I'm going to talk about that in
just one second but first but first we
need to talk about how you brush your
teeth so one of the most important
things that you do for your health every
day is brush your teeth but most of us
don't do a properly quip is a better
electric toothbrush it is created by
dentists and designers quit was designed
to make brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even enjoyable I bring my
equipped toothbrush on the road because
it is easy to pack you're enough to
bring one of those bulky charging
stations this this particular toothbrush
provides you sensitive sonic vibrations
a built-in two-minute timer it pulses
every 30 seconds to remind you want to
switch sides helping to guide a full and
even clean it has a multi-use cover
mount which sticks to your mirror and
Unbounce to slide over the bristles for
on-the-go brushing and best of all the
brushes are automatically delivered
because when's the last time you replace
your brush head you know
or do you because you didn't write it on
your calendar it wasn't that important
to you and now it's been six years since
you actually replaced that brush head
and it's just disgusting that is why you
need brush heads that are automatically
delivered on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just
five bucks that's why I like go to equip
right now at get quick comm slash
Shapiro and quip it starts at just 25
dollars right now your first refill pack
for free with a quip electric toothbrush
that is your first refill pack free at
get quip comm slash Shapiro GE tqu IP
comm slash up here I'll go check it out
right now okay well speaking of doing
the things that America needs to do to
keep itself safe we are not going to do
one crucial thing and it's going to be a
serious problem for us that crucial
thing is we are not going to pay down
our national debt nor are we going to
take the measures necessary to pay down
our national debt the reason I discuss
this is because today the Wall Street
Journal is reporting on a development
that people who have actually studied
American governance have known about for
years apparently the u.s. dest the u.s.
debt is going to cost us more in the
near future than our own national
defense that's just the the service on
our own debt thanks to the weakness of
the global economy tremendous there was
tremendous appetite for Americans at
write we were able to sell our debt and
and everybody's going to buy it because
America was still the best bet in the
global economy but that could soon be
ending according to The Wall Street
Journal the Congressional Budget Office
estimates interest spending is gonna
rise to 915 billion dollars by 2028 or
13% of all outlays and 3.1 percent of
gross domestic product along that path
the government is expected to pass the
following milestones will spend more on
interest and we spend on Medicaid in
2020 by 2023 more than we spend on
national defense by 2025
more than we spend on all non-defense
discretionary programs combined from
funding for national parks to scientific
research in other words we are spending
ourselves into oblivion and neither
party has an interesting curbing this
Democrats don't have an interest in
curbing this because they like the
spending eventually it's going to lead
us to Nordic tax rates which is exactly
what they want this is why they're
talking about blowing out the debt even
further they want Medicare for all they
want free college and all this is going
to cost tens of trillions of dollars
over the next 10 to 15 years they don't
care about that because in the end what
they actually want is a middle class tax
hike you can't tax the rich enough in
this country to pay for all this stuff
everybody on the Left knows this they're
lying about it what they want is sixty
percent tax rates for everybody making
about 50 grand in the country
because that's what the tax rates are in
places like Norway and Sweden and
Denmark so Democrats are fine with all
of this and they're lying about what
cost us money they say well it's the war
in Iraq or the war in Afghanistan it's
the tax cuts that is not the stuff that
is bankrupting the country the stuff
that is bankrupting the country is
Social Security Medicaid Medicare it is
those three programs that represent
something like sixty percent of the
entire American budget meanwhile
Republicans are gun shy of this stuff
for good reason they are deeply afraid
that if they touch any of these third
rails then their political support will
collapse which is why President Trump
has made it a point never to talk about
entitlement reform he doesn't want to
touch entitlement reform he's afraid of
entitlement reform Paul Ryan will leave
office without having touched
entitlement reform and all this means
that we are going to run this cut right
over the cliff and then we'll have two
parties that are either that are having
arguments about cutting around the edges
right austerity programs around the
edges or raising taxes dramatically and
that's because right now we don't have a
principled enough American people in the
end it's up to the voters to actually do
the right thing here the American people
are not calling for the sort of
structural changes that are necessary
because they don't see the crisis until
the crisis actually materializes I'm old
enough term I was part of the Tea Party
I'm old enough remember when we talked
about fiscal responsibility let's be
frank about this president Trump was
blown out the debt and Barack Obama blew
out the debt President Trump is blowing
out that right now the debt is rising at
faster rates than it was under Barack
Obama largely because of the tax cuts
but also because Trump has not slowed
spending in any serious way Republicans
are so deeply afraid of touching this
issue that they are going to leave
office without ever having touched the
issue which is going to lead to economic
chaos because the other thing to
remember is all the other countries that
have been able to blow out their their
debt to GDP ratio they've always been
able to rely on the economic growth
provided by the United States what
happens when the United States is no
longer providing that economic growth
because we've had to undergo these
massive tax increases or because we've
had to undergo massive austerity things
could get very ugly very quickly if we
don't start to take a look at these
issues and bad things are going to
happen unfortunately we're instead going
to focus on the 2020 election and the
and the Rock'em Sock'em robots of the
next presidential election so according
to Mark Penn and Andrew Stein both
Democratic operatives they think Hillary
Clinton's gonna run again really I know
every day we stray further from God's
light
the so they have a piece today called
Hillary will run again in The Wall
Street Journal says get ready for
Hillary Clinton 4.0 the last upgrade
really sucked so I'm hoping that Hillary
Clinton 4.0 the upgrade is actually
slightly less robotic she definitely
lives in the uncanny valley for folks
who are who are fans of sort of
computer-generated films there's
something in computer-generated films
called the uncanny valley where if you
if you put a human face on a computer it
looks slightly creepy to you if you
watch Polar Express right Polar Express
looks kind of creepy is famous for this
because it lives in the uncanny valley
the characters look too much like humans
for you to for you to think that they're
animated but they don't look enough like
humans to actually feel comfortable with
them that's Hillary Clinton she lives in
the uncanny valley she's been there for
her entire career according to Mark Penn
and Andrew Stein she is going to run
again they say that she is she's going
to come back stronger than ever she has
a 75% approval rating among Democrats an
unfinished mission to be the first
female president and a personal
grievance against mr. Trump who
supporters pilloried her with chance of
lock her up this must be avenged
they expect Hillary four-point-oh to
come out swinging with her cane
presumably she has decisively to win
those Iowa caucus-goers who have never
warmed up to her they will now see her
as a strong partisan left-leaning and
all Democrat the one with the guts
experience in Seeley I determination to
defeat mr. Trump mrs. Clinton knows both
mr. Clinton and mr. Obama declared they
weren't running until they ran she may
even skip Iowa enter the race later but
rest assured
Hillary 4.0 is on the way well you know
those of us on the right who recall
president from beating her we say this
would be the worst idea Democrats ever
had I'm not quite so sanguine about that
you know Hillary Clinton hand-picked
president Trump like she actually wanted
him to run thinking that if he runs I'll
swap him and then obviously she didn't
it's a dangerous game trying to handpick
your opponent because God doesn't like
it very much I just get the feeling that
God God thinks that you're your hubris
must be must be dealt with here's the
problem for president Trump we're all
very saying when that Hillary Clinton is
deeply unpopular that President Trump is
able to drag her through the mud all of
that is true Hillary Clinton lost in
2016 not merely because President Trump
successfully dragged her down into the
mud but also because no Democrat cared
about her her actual and popularity
ratings among Democrats were not good a
lot of Democrats in shop to vote for her
the reason that she lost is because no
one showed up to vote for her in
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin if you
look the actual if you look the actual
percentage vote that Trump won in those
three swing states that he won there
directly in line with the percentages
that were won by George W Bush and Mitt
Romney in those states he won the
state's Bush and Romney both lost the
states why because people turned out to
vote for John Kerry people turned out to
vote for Barack Obama nobody turned out
to vote for Hillary Clinton does anyone
on the right really think that that is
going to repeat itself in 2020 the
Democrats aren't gonna show up to vote
the turnout was unbelievably large for
2018 this midterm election the turnout
was significantly higher than 2014 in
many areas that surpassed the turnout in
a presidential year in 2016 Democrats
are extraordinarily motivated and one of
the reasons they're extraordinarily
motivated is because President Trump is
a very polarizing figure and those of us
on the right are happy with that those
of us on the right are enjoying a lot of
that we're enjoying watching him battled
the Democrats in battle the media but
what we saw in this last election cycle
is that there was in fact a slow rolling
blue wave there's a lot of taco it
wasn't a blue wave that was the early
result I said very early on this is not
a blue wave there's only one problem as
the results have been coming in this
looks more and more like a blue wave by
the end of this election cycle when all
the votes are tallied it looks like it's
gonna be R plus 2 in the Senate maybe
right we were 10 rick Scott's seat in
Florida it'll be R plus 2 in the Senate
in a in a in a midterm election cycle in
which there were 10 vulnerable
Democratic seats Republicans would have
picked up 2 right that is that is not a
good showing and in the house they're
gonna lose up to 40 seats which is it
which is a blowout they lost all of the
suburbs none of this is particularly
good Democrats also swamped Republicans
in state legislatures across the country
right the they picked up something like
four point six percent of state houses
they were claims more than 250 of the
many seats lost during Barack Obama's
presidency and they gained enough seats
to deprive Republicans of super
majorities in Michigan North Carolina
and Pennsylvania
they've been making serious ground in
all of the areas in which President
Trump actually needs to win and this has
led to a bit of a of a crisis for
Republicans who are willing to see it
and I think that crisis is good I think
the Republicans need to think strongly
about what they're going to do next now
listen there is one plan one plan is we
the democrats blow it right and that
that plan is not terrible my democrats
have a habit of blowing winnable
elections although the margin for error
is getting very slim christian cinema is
gonna be the next senator in arizona
which is insane okay Kristen cinema in
in Arizona is an actual nutcase right
she said in 2003 she didn't mind if
Americans joined the Taliban she's gonna
be the senator from Arizona and
Kristen's cinema is a person who went
around the United States legitimately
shouting at people that Arizona was a
terrible state she's going to be the
senator from Arizona that's how bad
things were in this election cycle for
Republicans should be martha mcsalley
the first female Air Force pilot to fly
in combat in that race
hey things are not looking good for
Republicans so even if the Democrats
were to run somebody completely nutty
which is sort of your hope in 2020
Republicans are gonna have to come up
with a better message in a second I want
to talk about what that better message
looks like and also why we may still be
able to count on Democrats being
completely out of their minds first
let's talk about your ancestry 23andme
is named for the 23 pairs of chromosomes
that make up your DNA 23andme is a
personal genetic service it helps you
understand what your DNA can tell you
about you and your family story so your
loved ones are getting together this
Thanksgiving discover more about the
genetic connections you share and show
that you have more Native American blood
than Elizabeth Warren at Thanksgiving
Elizabeth Warren claim the choose Native
American she has in fact whiter than the
backside of this sheet of paper and you
can go into Thanksgiving and say that
you are more closely related to Squanto
then then Elizabeth Warren is actually
the 23andme ancestry service allows you
to see how your DNA breaks out across
150 regions worldwide trace parts of
your ancestry to a specific group of
individuals from a thousand plus years
ago you can discover how much in the and
earth all DNA you inherited I fear how
much American vote how many American
voters have a lot of Neanderthal DNA
based on the midterm elections but go
check out 23andme right now because you
know because they have all of this great
stuff I mean not only do they have these
share and compare tools where you can
explore genetic similarities and
differences between you and your
relatives and not only do they have the
Neanderthal ancestry test they also can
tell you whether you are lactose
intolerant they can tell you whether
whether you whether you have certain
genetic predispositions to certain
certain conditions go check out 23andme
right now now through Thanksgiving
23andme ancestry service kits are only
forty nine bucks per kit when you buy
two
more that's 50% off the regular kit
price of 99 bucks this holiday again
order 23andme at 23andme comm slash
Shapiro that's two three and me.com
slash Shapiro go check it out right now
23andme comm slash appear oh okay well
we are going to continue the show in
just a second but for that you're gonna
have to go over to daly wire comm and
subscribe when you subscribe you get the
rest of the show live you get the rest
of the Andrew Clavin show live the rest
of Michael Moses show live we we usually
have our mug our our leftist here's how
to recalled tumblr we usually bring it
with us on the road and then it takes on
its properties of invisibility we didn't
bring it today unfortunately but when
you get the annual subscription for $99
a year then you get that tumbler as well
so go check it out we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk about what
Republicans can actually do to recover
number one as I say they can count on
Democrats being insane
I think accounts on Maxine Waters being
the head of the Financial Services
Committee so Maxine Waters who
apparently is going to take up that
chairmanship she says that what
Republicans are truly scared of is
strong black women like Maxine Waters no
I'm just scared of Maxine Waters herself
like strong black women totally fine
Mia loves great and Connie Connie is
great maxine waters scared of her
because she calls riots uprisings in Los
Angeles where I am from legitimately as
we watched the city burn during the LA
riots in 1991 she was walking around
talking about I was in LA uprising she
says now that the GOP is just scared of
strong black women like Maxine Waters I
don't make anything that's the
opposition talking about what would
happen if this strong black woman Maxine
Waters is a chair of the Financial
Services Committee they have never seen
anybody like me before there's never
been a woman in the history of this
country that's been the chairperson of
the Financial Services Committee and
certainly never a black woman and so
they send out these dog whistles to
their constituents to get them fired up
about the possibility of what Maxine
Waters might do well I'm more scared
about the possibility that Maxine Waters
may in fact use the Financial Services
Committee to commit financial
impropriety because it turns out that
her relatives by 2004 had made more than
a million bucks during the preceding
eight years by doing business with
companies candidates and causes that
water's had helped she was named one of
the most corrupt members of Congress in
2005 2006 2009 2011 by the leftist
watchdog group Citizens for
responsibility and ethics in Washington
when she worked on the Financial
Services Committee during the downturn
she arranged meetings between US
Treasury Department officials in one
United Bank where her husband was an
executive so that the bank could plead
for federal cash so yeah I'm more afraid
of her being just a corrupt terrible
human being than I am of her race but
this is going to be the pitch the
Democrats run then then Republicans have
a shot Republicans have been able to
count on the intersectional politics of
the Democrats for a very long time
hopefully they can continue to count on
that and Democrats are taking the wrong
lessons from the 2018 elections which is
good right the overwhelming
including the victory of Christian
cinema in Arizona it could have a silver
lining
Christian cinema is so nuts the
Democrats may think oh you know what she
won in Arizona we can run complete crazy
people straight from Arkham Asylum and
they will absolutely win it'll all be
fine I mean they nearly won in Georgia
with the candidate Stacey Abrams who
talked about full-scale gun confiscation
so maybe they maybe they get to see
maybe they deceive themselves Michelle
Goldberg who's an expert at defeat at
deceiving herself an opinion columnist
over the New York Times the worst
editorial page in America she says it
took a while for the conventional wisdom
of the American political class
accustomed to treating Democrats as
hapless and disorganized to catch up to
what the resistance had accomplished all
over the country three of the marquee
candidates progressives were most
excited about Andrew Gilman Florida
Stacey Abrams in Georgia bethe O'Rourke
in Texas seemed to fall short but by the
end of the night it was clear that the
Democrats had won the house and in the
following days new races kept being
called they're a bunch of progressives
who have won and this means that
progressivism is triumphant all over the
country well maybe we can somehow
deceive Democrats into continuing to
believe this progressivism was not in
fact triumphant all over the country of
the eight candidates who are the most
progressive as labeled by the nation all
eight of them lost
Andrew Gilliam if he had lost his
primary bronzes chances would not be the
future governor of Florida Stacey Abrams
she'd been slightly more moderate would
have won in Georgia Democrats were like
this close to a full-out sweep if they'd
not been completely not so maybe it'll
be the same thing in 2020 and the
evidence is is there that Democrats are
doubling down on a lot of this stuff and
the and its social evidence is there too
I mean there's a really bad story over
the weekend Tucker Carlson when was
accused of supposedly assaulting a guy
in Tucker Carlson put out a statement
where he said that's not what happened
apparently what happened is he was
eating dinner at a place with his family
and his daughter who's 19 went to the
bathroom and this guy went up to her and
called her a and so Tucker Carlson
was already outside of the restaurant by
this point his son went back in through
wine on the guy here is a video of the
confrontation
so again I mean there was there they
were saying that Carlson assaulted the
guy he didn't he never I mean honestly
if somebody called my daughter a
in public like the last the this would
be the the mild edge of what would
happen to them but unfortunately there
are a lot of folks on the Left who are
willing to embrace this sort of politics
we saw that last week after after this
happened with Tucker's house remember
last week Tucker's house was was
confronted by an Tifa members people
went to his door they tried to break
through his door people like Matt
Iglesias had fought voxcom
came out and said that he deserved it so
it's possible the left will deceive
itself into being completely naughty in
2020 and Republicans will win but there
is a better path to Republicans winning
in 2020 and that's becoming better at
their jobs and own talk about that in
just a second so evidence that
Republicans can be good at their jobs
there's a congressional candidate named
Dan Crenshaw he just became a new
Congress person and he's really terrific
I'm big Dan Crenshaw fan you'll remember
him from last week because Saturday
Night Live Pete Davidson made fun of him
on the show he's a former member of the
military former Navy SEAL he's one of
the 16 veterans newly elected to the
House in the midterm elections he's
representing Texas his second district
and Pete Davidson had made some sort of
offhand nasty remark about how he looked
like a James Bond villain and who cares
whether he lost his eye in a war or
something and there was a lot of
blowback for it well Dan Crenshaw
handled this about as well as it was
possible to handle anything he came out
and listen I'm not gonna pretend I'm a
victim of Pete Davidson when I've fought
in wars come on but you know the guy's
kind of a he's kind of a jerk and you
should respect military members more
well Pete Davidson actually did
something good Pete Davidson invited him
on Saturday Night Live and this I
thought was one of the better political
moments that we've seen in American
politics over the past several years
here is what it sounded like
there's a lot of lessons to learn here
not just that the left and right can
still agree on some things but also this
Americans can forget one
we can remember what brings us together
as a country and still see the good in
each other this is Veterans Day weekend
which means that it's a good time for
every American to connect with a veteran
maybe say thanks for your service but I
would actually encourage you to say
something else tell a veteran never
forget when you say never forget to a
veteran you are implying that as an
American you are in it with them not
separated by some imaginary barrier
between civilians and veterans but
connected together as grateful fellow
Americans will never forget the
sacrifices made by veterans past and
present and never forget those we lost
on 9/11 heroes like Pete's father
so I'll just say Pete never forget never
forget so I mean that's really good
stuff and good for Dee and Crenshaw
handled that the best possible way they
also let him come on and mock Pete
Davidson's appearance which is easy
pickings and so so good really good for
both of them that's the kind of politics
where Republicans can reach out to new
voters that way how they can't reach out
is doubling down on what brought them
there now again 2016 was an amazing
election is amazing election for a
number of reasons but what brought you
to 2016 is not necessarily what's going
to take you to victory in 2020 between
2000 and 2004 george w bush had to pick
up 11 million additional votes to
slightly beat John Kerry in 2004 those a
close election Donald Trump lost by 2.5
million popular votes he won by 80,000
votes in three states I mean he ran the
narrowest gauntlet you can run I mean
there's just no way to run that more
narrow way basically if if there had
been a sneeze in Michigan he would have
lost that state I
he needs to somehow pick up millions of
additional voters can he do that simply
by tweeting things out I understand it
delights all of us in the base I
understand that when he says things that
it's fun to watch him go and it's fun to
watch him slap and I'm not saying that
he shouldn't do any of that
I'm just saying channel your aggression
like a good boxer knows when to put his
hands up and when to punch if you're
constantly windmilling your hands are
gonna get socked in the face an awful
lot President Trump is good at taking a
punch but the rest of the party can't
take punches the way that President
Trump can when President Trump gets
punched it gets felt in georgia's 6th
district Trump doesn't feel it he's only
up for election every four years but we
did feel it in suburban districts across
the country so what would you rather
the kind of republicanism that is that
is making waves across the country Jane
Crenshaw or President Trump tweeting
about fires and the fires in California
where I live are really quite awful
they've now expands it all the way from
Thousand Oaks out to the coast they
burned all the way down to the water
taking a bunch of house where they
burned out Malibu
they are moving toward Woodland Hills
right now and there are 40 40
mile-per-hour winds that are they've
really been kicking I mean like you can
see it looks like a mushroom cloud you
can actually see the clouds from my
house like Russia from Sarah Palin's
house but you can actually see the
clouds in the sky and then the ash is
falling from the sky and the midst of
that President Trump tweeted out there
is no reason for these massive deadly
and costly forest fires in California
except that forest management is so poor
billions of dollars are given each year
with so many lives lost all because of
gross mismanagement of the forest
remedy now or no more Fed payments hey
is that useful in any conceivable way of
course not of course that's not useful
in any conceivable way if he wants to
change federal forest management policy
he's the president of the United States
he certainly can do that if he wants to
negotiate behind-the-scenes with Jerry
Brown in California and tried to
structure how exactly California handles
its wildlife management he can do that
too but the reality of the situation is
that two-thirds of the lands are the
public lands in California are run by
the federal government directly and
another two-thirds after that are run by
private foundations so it's not just
that the state of California was
incompetent and therefore President
Trump can do this sort of stuff if
President Trump put down the phone
honest to god if he put down the phone
and somehow we found a way to drain his
battery or if we construct it as I'd
suggested to the White House a separate
Twitter app that allows him to tweet out
but it's actually a closed app so it
doesn't actually go anywhere and just
feeds him back statistics about retweets
and a bunch of things like maggle you're
doing great and he's all happy all day
like that would be the best way to do it
because when he punches publicly
sometimes it's very good but as I've
said literally since the day he
announced the man is a hammer in search
of a nail sometimes use a nail sometimes
gets a baby and if you had a baby too
often it turns out people don't like it
and people are gonna make people who are
allied with you pay the price for it we
are very polarized country right now 96%
of all seats that Hillary Clinton won by
more than seven one Democrat in the last
election more than 96% of all seats
Trump won by more than seven went
Republican in the last election there
are no more swing districts or at least
very very few swing districts that means
Republicans don't have a lot of room for
error
okay time for a thing I like and then a
couple of things that I hate so things
that I like today over the weekend I was
reading a very good book on sports
called the last pass about Bob Cousy
Bill Russell and and the things that
matter it's it's a it's a really good
biography of Bob Cousy if you're a
basketball fan it's kind of fun to read
I like reading sports books a lot and
this one is particularly good also but
well I like this book there's something
I like even more and that is Trumpy bear
so I was not aware of Trumpy bear Trumpy
bear is a new one to me
but on Twitter this morning Trumpy bear
started making the rounds no one is
coming you cannot defeat the store
I am the store the great American
grizzly introducing the original Trumpy
bear just find the secret zipper and
pull out the American flag themed
blanket then wrap yourself in the red
white and blue for comfort and warmth
show your patriotism and proudly
displayed from beyond any American
holiday god Bless America and God bless
Trumpy bear Trumpy bear loves to cruise
with his brother I'm a former Marine and
I'm proud to have Trumpy Bear ride by my
side when I ride with Trumpy bear he
makes my golf game great again
thank you Trump you back simply style
his trademark hair and place it in his
favorite chair even the toughest guys
will love Trump II bear
order the Super Plus Trump ebail for
only two payments of 1995 no I'll
acknowledge my first saw this I imagine
immediately this was a national scale
right I mean there's no way to watch
that and that was an actual commercial
that ran on Fox News as an action and I
will admit I want to buy it right I mean
I want to and you have to admire
American ingenuity I mean this is a
great stupid country I mean this is a
it's a great country that bear is worth
approximately seven bucks and 95 cents
they're selling it for two payments of
1995 all right so with shipping I looked
it up today because I was thinking
Secret Santa gift for Christmas office
party that'd be good right 56 dollars
for a bear with a flag in the back but
at least you get to own the libs I guess
it's I do love it like it appeals to so
many terrible things that are happening
right now in the country it appeals to
the idea that that President Trump is
the country president Trump is
patriotism the flag that comes out of
the back like you have to get it as a
gag gift for a Democrat I assume but it
is the fact that they thought that there
was an audience for that
I would actually see that sin like I
would buy it out of irony right you they
I would imagine most people who buy this
buy this out just out of ironic love for
it because the commercial is so
over-the-top but there are certain
number of people who if you buy that if
you bought Trumpy bear out of irony out
of not irony if you bought it sincerely
I please reexamine your life if you
bought Trumpy bear because you were
sincere about your love for Trumpy bear
and because you think that like they're
a fireman who drive around with Trumpy
bear in the back of the firetruck in all
sincerity please just Wow Wow
but good for capitalism we make money
off anything in this country okay time
for a couple of things that I hate okay
so thing number one Sam Donaldson who
apparently he put on a toupee in 1985
and now it's too late to make the change
Sam Donaldson was talking about
president Trump space and he says
trumpism will never be a majority he's
on CNN talking about all of this and it
was not great his small base and I think
there are minority who believe if the
Nazis and the protestors are on both
sides there are good people on both
sides
his small base is not gonna run this
country they don't know and they never
will that is some wild hair well the
reason that I bring this up is because I
actually met Sam Donaldson at like the
2012 RNC in Tampa and he was wandering
around who's been doing an opinion show
for ABC News radio and I walked up to
him and I said to him so do you hold the
same opinions now that you did back in
the 1980s when you were being a reporter
Sam Donaldson he said yes and I said
well so were you lying then are you
lying now I mean you said you're an
objective journalist then and now you
say you're an opinion guy so which is it
and he got very angry at me those
eyebrows started coming at me out of the
dark and he and he said and I'm not a
man who can rip another man's eyebrows
usually but Sam Donaldson has me trumped
and in Sam Donaldson he says so do you
think that you're better than I have you
think you're more honest than I said
well yeah I do actually because I'm
pretty upfront about where I stand on
these issues and you lied about it for
twenty thirty years of your career while
covering President Trump the fact that
Sam Donaldson is being brought on as an
analyst on mainstream media networks is
is evidence of all of this and it is
demonstrative again of why
President Trump does still have an
enormous amount of Appeal specifically
to his base president Trump's number-one
opposition is not the Democrats his
number-one opposition is is not even
foreign adversaries in many ways his
number-one opposition is the media and
that's because the media are constantly
shifting the narrative about him now I
don't believe in the language enemy of
the people that he uses because I just
don't like that language is bad
historical antecedents but when
President Trump talks about the the
remarkable unity of goal and rhetoric
from the members of the press he is not
wrong about any of that he is exactly
right in fact about all of it and Sam
Donaldson who was the most champion
reporter of the 1980s right he was the
guy he was the key reporter of the 1980s
day I was standing up to Ronald Reagan
he was no different than Jim Acosta
he just had weird her eyebrows the
meanwhile on CNN speaking of people who
look like inanimate objects Chris Cuomo
who is a block of wood and started
slamming people for expressing thoughts
and prayers again in the aftermath of a
shooting in California
here is Chris Cuomo doing one more
obnoxious routines that has become
commonplace in mainstream media because
that's what you do when you offer
thoughts and prayers you mock those who
lost loved ones because if you gave it
any thought at all you would never walk
away from any of these without figuring
out a better way to deal with them and
prayer you think leaving it to God is
the answer we pray for strength we pray
for wisdom for resolve but we clearly
don't want to act on any of those here
so what are you praying for what would
it take how about a stadium full of
children of the most influential people
in our society all holding puppies what
if they were all shot and killed would
we act oh don't be ridiculous to suggest
something like is it is it ridiculous
more ridiculous than doing nothing yes
it is ridiculous suggesting that things
would radically change if there were a
stadium full of five-year-olds holding
teddy bears who were shot that this
would suddenly change everything yes
that's ridiculous number one because
that's not going to happen and number
two because the insanity of of Chris
Cuomo sitting there and suggesting that
there's a whole group of people in the
United States who don't care if children
get killed because we want to keep our
guns is disgusting you want to know
where the passion for Trump comes from
you know where the passion from the
right comes from it comes from watching
people like Chris Cuomo more than
anything else when people like Chris
Cuomo sit there and lecture us about how
we don't
care enough about dead kids and so
thoughts and prayers are useless he has
not yet named a single policy that he
could promulgate that would stop the
mass shooting that happened in
California it was done not with an ar-15
but with a handgun there are already
laws on the books in California the
would have a law that would have allowed
the shooters mother to go to the police
and tried to have his guns removed from
him laws were already present in the
state of California for universal
background checks for 10-day waiting
periods for it to make Harry it's a may
grant state in terms of concealed carry
licenses California is the number one
gun controlled state in America there
was a mass shooting there and Chris
Cuomo says this is obviously due to lack
of will the NRA is not even operative in
the state of California gun owners have
a minority viewpoint in the state of
California it doesn't matter one iota
when it comes to mass shootings we've
have five serious mass shootings in the
last six years in the state of
California when Chris Cuomo tries to
suggest that everybody who disagrees
with him is merely throwing things off
the is merely delaying policy making
when they say thoughts and prayers it is
deeply deeply insulting to religious
people who actually believe in prayer
and is deeply insulting to everybody who
disagrees with him on policy who may not
believe that his preferred solutions are
either effective at stopping mass
shootings or minimizing the extent of
those shootings when the damage becomes
known okay well we will be back here
tomorrow with all the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
Ford publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018